Jennifer Lopez spends time with new beau  Alex Rodriguez's family  [Music]  things sure seem to be getting serious  between JLo and a-rod the 47 year old  singer has already met some of the  former Yankee stars family I can't help  it on Friday Alex's sister Suzie took to  Instagram to share two fun snaps of  herself having a girls day with Jennifer  judging by her caption she clearly  approves of her brother's new love  writing in Spanish sister-in-law the  night before the family hangout Jennifer  and Alex shared a romantic date night in  Miami from couples workout sessions to  their Bahamas trip the pair has been  spending a lot of quality time together  he's just been super loving and  supportive  [Music]  you